hello everyone today here I've got a
stack of physics books that I got out
from the library and they all deal with
ideas relating to time or space and time
travel I thought it would be really
interesting to see how these books go
about describing and illustrating time
travel because time travel is something
that usually belongs in fiction books or
sci-fi and is treated in a very fanciful
way but these are non-fiction books and
some are written by quite serious
scientists so I thought it would be
interesting to see how they unravel the
same ideas and how time travel is
treated by people who are dedicated to
studying it the first book in our lineup
today is geometry relativity and the
fourth dimension by Rudy Rucker now if
you've been following my short videos
about the fourth dimension you'll have
met some ideas from this book already
but tucked away in its chapters there's
a compelling discussion on time travel
this diagram here is to get us thinking
in terms of space-time it shows these
flat slices of our world that are moving
forward in time in this particular
example there are two characters a
square and a triangle living on a flat
plane this is what their world looks
like at 12 o'clock but five minutes
later at the slice 1205 the triangle has
moved towards the square maybe to say
hello and then five minutes later again
at 12 10 the triangle has moved away
meaning that in space-time you could
draw the triangle as a worm that snakes
over here and then back again whereas Mr
Square remains stationary the entire
time and their world line is just this
straight line this just shows two
characters but you could try to
represent the entire world or Universe
using these World lines and it would be
a vast tangle of worms you could
represent every atom by one line and
because every atom in a person's body is
replaced every seven years or so there
wouldn't actually be a single thread
that goes the whole length of a person's
life a living individual is a persistent
pattern of world lines rather than a
particular collection of particles
during World lines helps you think of
space-time as a structure all of its own
where the universe at any instant is a
3D cross-section but that does make us
wonder why we can't see the past or
future if they really exist one idea is
that maybe all instance of time do exist
but because our memories only relate to
events that happened at previous time
steps to our present moment we get the
illusion that we are moving forwards in
time always the offer then makes a
slight departure from physics but this
next diagram helps me to understand
meditation better than any yoga class
I've been to he asks if there is a way
to be conscious in a static space time
instead of always moving forwards well
one trick to achieve the feeling of
timelessness is to stop thinking new
thoughts because without that it's hard
to distinguish one moment from the next
to achieve this timelessness you could
either think nothing at all which is not
easy or concentrate your attention on a
repetitive thought Loop like a mantra
thinking nothing you can't differentiate
one instant from the next and doing a
mantra you can't differentiate one
repetition of the Mantra from the next
this next diagram here shows a way to
time travel to the Past although it only
works in a universe where time is
circular in this universe the time
Dimension is wrapped into a cylinder and
space extends infinitely out to the
sides the circle here represents the
world line of the earth if we say that
it takes one trillion years for time to
repeat itself so that is the
circumference of this world line to time
travel we could leave the Earth speeding
off to the side for say a quarter of a
trillion years then we could turn around
and travel back this way for say half a
trillion years then turn around again
and take another quarter of a trillion
years to get back to where we started
but because time is circular we will
intersect the world line of the Earth in
its past ideas of circular time have
been proposed in physics but there are
plenty of practical reasons why a
journey like this taking a trillion
years and needing to travel close to the
speed of light is not going to work
you'd need a rocket the size of a Galaxy
to have enough fuel and you'd probably
get lost this next book is Paul Davies
about time in a chapter on time reversal
there is a discussion about antimatter
and how there are things called
positrons which are like anti-electrons
they have the opposite charge but maybe
they also go back in time electrons and
positrons are created together in pairs
usually it's from a photon colliding
with an atom they fly off and hope to
never see each other again because if a
positron were to run into an electron
then the pair would instantly annihilate
and reverse this pair creation process
giving back photons this is a space time
diagram where here a photon coming into
point a creates an electron positron
pair the positron then meets with
another electron and annihilates giving
back a photon at this time T an observer
would see three particles an electron a
positron and another electron but
according to Richard Feynman this zigzag
track could be viewed as the world line
of just one particle an electron that
travels back in time between these
Annihilation and creation events that's
why the arrow here for the positron is
pointing backwards feynman's theory was
that this is all just one electron and
it travels back in time for that brief
period where it is considered a positron
this idea could be extended to include
many more electrons and positrons and
you could say that all the electrons in
the universe are just the same one
particle that there is just one electron
making up the entire universe it offers
a nice explanation for why all electrons
appear to be identical but that Theory
comes with problems of its own it would
also predict that the universe is made
exactly of half matter and half
antimatter but we don't see nearly as
much antimatter as we do normal matter
and the arrow of time in our universe
appears to point forwards rather than
having a Sim a tree pointing backwards
another way to time travel to the past
is detailed in this next book time
travel in Einstein's Universe by J
Richard Gott got mentioned something
called cosmic strings which are thin
strands of high density material left
over from the early Universe this
diagram is designed to show what
space-time looks like around a cosmic
string it's like a piece of pizza
missing a slice if we take out that
slice and stick it together we get a
cone here my pencil is the cosmic string
and The Cone is what a horizontal plane
of space-time around the string looks
like suppose that here's the Earth
here's the cosmic string and here is a
quasar split across the region of the
missing slice these straight lines show
the path that light would take from the
Quasar to reach Earth and here's what
those paths look like in the conical
space time to us on Earth it will appear
as if there are two different quasares
even though it's the same object and
even though the light is traveling on
the shortest straightest path to us from
the Quasar one of the paths will be
shorter this is the principle of
gravitational lensing and maybe what
helps us to find cosmic strings the
light traveling along path too has
beaten the light traveling along path
one and if it was a rocket traveling
along path too traveling at nearly the
speed of light it could have also beaten
light path one if cosmic strings exist
then you could travel in a spaceship and
outrun a light beam by taking the
shorter of two parts around a cosmic
string when the rocket arrives at Earth
the light showing its departure from the
Quasar won't have arrived yet so you
could look back and see yourself still
on the Quasar about to depart on another
page in this book there's instructions
on how to build a time machine that can
visit the future to construct this time
machine you need to find the mass of the
planet Jupiter and construct it around
yourself into a spherical shell that
will create a huge gravitational well
around you but because it's a sphere it
will perfectly cancel out in every
direction and inside the shell you will
feel unaffected we're just teetering on
the limit of mass concentration that
would create a black hole so you don't
want to go overboard with this just
outside of the spherical shell you would
be torn apart by tidal forces generated
by its gravitational attraction but
inside the sphere you would be perfectly
safe this diagram simplifies the
situation down to just a two-dimensional
shell so it's drawn around this time
traveler here as a circle but for us it
would actually be a sphere if you
imagine an ant falling into something
this shape it would require a lot of
energy to crawl back out the same thing
will happen with our photons photons
emitted by us will lose a lot of energy
on the way out and be redshifted turning
into longer wavelength light photons
from outside of the well that fall in
will pick up energy as they fall the
person inside of the well would see
these waves oscillating faster than they
did on the outside and if the people
outside the well had been using a clock
which relied on the oscillation of these
waves the person inside of the well
would see these clocks to be ticking
four times faster if the time traveler
managed to safely disassemble the well
he would step out of his time machine
and be younger than those around him
another way to time travel to the future
is by moving really fast usually running
away on a rocket going near the speed of
light leaving Earth for a bit then
turning around and coming back and being
younger than everyone around you I think
this diagram does a good job of
explaining why a clock on a rocket ship
moving fast actually ticks more slowly
than one that's left on Earth if you
construct a clock that uses the bouncing
of light off mirrors to measure the time
then this is what our clock on Earth
would look like the light would
predictably bounce between the two
mirrors and the clock would tick every
time it hit one give that same clock to
an astronaut on a moving rocket and if
we observed that astronaut from the
outside of their space station this is
what we would see the mirrors are still
separated by the same distance but
because the rocket is moving past us we
will see the light bounce off the bottom
mirror and then bounce off the top
mirror but the distance between the
mirrors will no longer be the initial
three feet separation it will be longer
because it's traveled on this diagonal
line because light travels at a constant
speed if it's traveling a greater
distance then there'll be a greater time
delay between these two ticks of the
clock so this astronauts clock will tick
more slowly compared to ours it will
happen to everything on board even the
astronaut's heart is a kind of clock and
that is why when the astronaut returns
to earth after their Journey they won't
have physically aged as much as someone
who was left on Earth
most books that mentioned time travel
will have one of these a minkowski or a
space-time diagram these diagonal lines
represent an object moving at the speed
of light anything less steep than that
will be inside of these cones and will
be from either the past or the future of
Point P because things can travel from
anywhere in this region 2p anything in
this cone could have affected P it is
its past light cone same with the future
anything from P could affect anything in
this region but these points A and B are
outside of the light cones this is the
region of Elsewhere whilst A and B might
happen at the same time as P they cannot
affect P because light could not travel
from here to here all observers agree on
the light paths because light travels at
the same speed for all observers but
depending on how fast you are moving
yourself the X C's x and t will actually
move and change based on your reference
frame and now here are some highly
commended extra entries space time
breaking up we're at a mini microscopic
level Quantum effects are so violent
that they start to tear space and time
apart completely creating a sponge-like
structure of wormholes and bridges this
activity would be unnoticed by even a
subatomic particle which would be larger
than the Wormhole this one shows a
rocket stuck inside of a black hole the
rocket is always dragged back down and
so are light signals that they try to
send out there's no escape and no way to
let anyone know that you are here this
figure shows black and white holes a is
a collapse to a black hole and B is an
explosion from a white hole this one's
too complicated for me to understand
enough to explain but the study of black
and white holes looks very cool here's
an interesting model called a
self-creating universe where the
universe has a Time loop at its
beginning meaning the question of what
happened before the universe existed
doesn't really apply because according
to this the universe is its own creation
and if you were to go back in time
throughout the history of the universe
you would end up intersecting with your
own tail
thanks for joining me on this look
through some Physics books thanks to my
patrons for making this video possible
and a special shout out to today's
patreon cat of the day freeway